el hobbit 19 vuelve a preocupar en
europa la ms señaló que el viejo
continente es la única región del mundo
con aumento de contagios en la última
semana en reino unido- la propagación
del virus no se detiene desde el
ministerio de salud advirtieron que el
país podría haber hasta 100.000 casos
diarios aunque de momento no planean
aplicar medidas de contención para no
dañar la economía pese a que en los
hospitales ya empieza a sentirse la
presión
estamos estudiando detenidamente los
datos y no pondremos en marcha nuestro
plan de medidas de contingencia en ese
momento pero nos mantendremos alerta
preparándonos para cualquier
eventualidad mientras reforzamos
nuestras defensas para luchar contra el
virus pues fight pack x force en rusia
tras el récord de muertes por el virus
el ejecutivo anunció una semana de
vacaciones remuneradas para los
ciudadanos el cierre temporal de los
servicios no esenciales e incentivo a la
vacunación ya que la campaña de
inmunización se está ralentizando por el
escepticismo de la población con las
vacunas personas
lo volveré a repetir la vacuna reduce el
riesgo de contagio de complicaciones
graves de la enfermedad el riesgo de
muerte por lo que por supuesto hago un
llamado a nuestros ciudadanos a que se
vacuna a
otros países como letonia también están
sufriendo estragos por el joven 19
de hecho la nación se ha convertido en
la primera del continente en volver al
confinamiento y al toque de queda que se
mantendrá hasta el 15 de noviembre estoy
vacunado y creo que es necesario y por
culpa de los que están en contra de las
vacunas estamos así con la medida el
gobierno letón espera bajar los
contagios y estimular la inmunización